et le problème c'est que ce monsieur
s'il n'est pas de leçon il fait ce qu'il
veut de ce weekend mais il donne des
sons sur la démocratie et dit la
République c'est moi il donne des sons
sur l'écologie il arrive en 4x4 bah
pardon
et puis finalement elle arrive avec la
voiture qui est par définition jeep
c'est une briquet une bride
monsieur polémique elle a été lancée et
relayée par Éric Naulleau qui déteste
Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc déjà ils sont
pas très objectif sur l'histoire de la
voiture française ils ont bien expliqué
donc une voiture de location qu'ils ont
cherché des voitures françaises qui n'en
avaient plus à l'occasion
stop c'est français c'est français vous
prenez pas la tête pour la voiture c'est
français c'est GIPS c'est fiable c'est
le groupe sémantis c'est Peugeot Citroën
excuse-moi
la voiture est française c'est le groupe
c'est l'antise Speedy la cravate on s'en
fout de la voiture française mais
hybride même hybride ça veut dire que
quand elle est en partie essence elle
consomme énormément donc je reviens sur
ce que dit Mathieu faites ce que je dis
faites pas ce que je fais machin il veut
tout faire mieux que tout le monde mais
en vérité quand tu as hybride ou pas
hybride s'il va sur l'autoroute il va
énormément consommer